we see in the sports management world
many examples of entrepreneurship
leading to both a lot of asset creation
and at times a lot of asset destruction
the sports world is a lot more complex
than your traditional venture capital
world because a lot of the players in
that world have multiple motives so
whereas a lot of VCS predominantly
driven by returns of a financial kind
the sports world has that plus it has
people who are really after power after
position after prestige and that causes
their decisions to not always be aligned
with financial interest the sources of
creation of wealth are multiple in this
area and we do have whole new ideas
coming in for new league's assets have
been created in new leagues that really
didn't exist before so the best example
of that is the Indian Premier League in
cricket and that's now a billion to two
billion dollars at least and it's only
about seven years old we have people
coming out of bankruptcy and creating
ventures that are in the billion dollars
of what some people call unicorns so the
ultimate fighting group out of Las Vegas
in the early 2000s took that out of
bankruptcy and now it's clearly worth
over a billion dollars as an asset class
itself we have whole new situations
where regional sports networks have been
set up that didn't exist and created a
lot of value for the owners so for
instance the yes network out of New York
I think was valued over three billion
dollars that didn't exist in 2000 so the
amount of opportunity to create wealth
in the sports industry I think people
have dramatically underestimated it
as with any entrepreneurship there's
both upside and downside and so there's
many examples of asset destruction and
so you want to look at what was the
causes of those so for example the NFL
although it's the dominant league there
have been many attempts to go after them
so the XFL was a league that started in
2001 as a joint venture between NBC and
the World Wrestling Entertainment that
lasted no longer than 10 weeks and just
went down in a flame we've had more
recently the UFL go after the position
in that market and that has lost
hundreds of millions there are regional
sports networks that have failed so for
instance Fox had a Chicago regional
sports network that unfortunately for
them they had misaligned the contracting
and overnight the value dissipated
because all the four teams in that
market got together and shifted to
somebody else so there's just a lot of
lessons from the destruction as well as
the creation understand the market did
you going into leverage as many players
as possible and just write very good
contracts and avoid writing bad
contracts and I think another thing is
to don't underestimate the time period
necessary that you're going to have to
maybe go cash flow negative to stay in
the game that a lot of it's just like
venture capital there is a period at
which you got to do investment these
things take longer especially if you're
trying to change consumer behavior some
of the technology ventures can take off
much quicker but the the idea is that in
the short run we overestimate how much
people's behavior is going to change but
in the long run there's profound changes
in people's behavior that the sports
industry as well as media in general can
explain